imagine having guests and they have to
witness that
makes me sick guys but in our new studio
it's totally different
and this is our entrance to our new
studio amazing
so this guy this flipping looks like a
potato yeah this potato uh over there
he's a potato he's a zionist potato yes
i'm calling i have no shame but he's a
zionist potato
roman abramovic yeah owner of the
premier league
football uh chelsea yeah let's get this
a bit faster donated 100 million to
ellard and israeli settler group yeah
you are stealing my house and if i don't
steal it someone else is going to steal
it
how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before
assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh brothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are well in
charlotte you guys might be aware of
this
on my left this guy this thief coming to
steal the lands of the palestinians
well did you guys know that this person
on my right roman abramovich who owns
chelsea uh this coward is actually
financing this guy
and i came to know about this while i
did a bit of digging now it wasn't the
kind of digging
which a far-right uh israeli
organization non-profit organization uh
called ilad
uh has been doing because they've been
doing some digging as well but that's
the
type of thing i've been doing because
they've been doing digging distilled
lands uh as an excuse
and the excuse they use this archaeology
we're gonna come to all of this what am
i talking about let's get straight into
it brothers and sisters did you guys
know
that roman abramovich what his name is i
don't want to pronounce it
um he gave nearly 100
million pounds to a far-right israeli
zionist thiefs organize a thief
organization
called ilat these people use archaeology
as an excuse to um take lands of the
palestinians you know say they believe
it's a city of
david in a specific region in in
palestine and they're using archaeology
to expand their oppression from the
sisters
and to steal lands that is the reason
why this video
let's play it right now inshallah and
react to it as you guys can see
you know this is not your house yes but
if i go you don't go back so what's the
problem what are you yelling at me i
didn't do this
i didn't do this it's usually to yell at
me but i didn't do this
you are stealing my house and if i don't
steer it someone else is going to steal
it
no no one no one is allowed to steal it
so this guy this flipping looks like a
potato yeah this potato uh over there
he's a potato he's a zionist potato yes
i'm calling i have no shame but he's a
zionist potato okay
he's a zionist potato and don't you dare
use anti-semitism don't you dare
yeah we've got the jewish community in
uh stamford hill who
oppose these very cowardice what are you
gonna say you're gonna say they're
anti-semitic as well
get the hell out of here boy you're
finished we have the evidence against
you yes
that's correct brother and sister
subhanallah as you can see
this potato over here is basically
saying look
it's already started you know elad this
this non-profit organization
uh far-right israeli organization
thief's organization
is using archaeology to take the lands
of the people by saying all these
historical sites and you know we need to
dig up and you know
et cetera sisters and this guy on my
left
is being funded by people like roman
abramovich what the hell his name is
yeah and he's funding them
so don't look somewhere else look over
here because they know these lands are
probably
going to be worth something in the long
run so they are investing in it and he's
not doing it directly he's doing it
through
setting up some um companies in the
caribbean islands
and getting those funds across and guess
what and like brother loki said
that these are the same organizations
that is funding
that is funding uh like people like
tommy robinson brothers sisters
the far right here in the uk they are
funding them that's the reason why tommy
robinson why he has so much
love towards israel where did that come
from yeah well if you're being paid you
know
and have a mansion with a jacuzzi i'm
sure you're going to be loving israel
your brother and sister inshallah so
brothers and sisters as you can see
clearly
the money that's been financed is by
this guy
to this person so in this video that i'm
going to pray
the video i'm going to play in charlotte
you can see this for yourself so here we
go
roman abramovic yeah owner of the
premier league
football uh chelsea yeah let's get this
a bit faster donated 100 million to
ellard and israeli settler group yeah
that displaces palestinian families from
occupied east jerusalem
abramovic is a russian national and was
granted israeli citizenship in 2018 his
fortune estimated between 12 to 13
billion leaked documents show
four companies run by abramovic donated
money over the last 15 years
funding more than half of allah's work
yeah brother sisters you can see clearly
subhanallah
these people and wallahi i've done
another video allah's message
to the palestinians brothers and sisters
subhanallah you can see the oppression
these people are doing and while
he have no doubt let them have their
couple of minutes because we're on this
earth
trust me like a day allah says that we
are going to be
when allah says how long was on earth
day or half a day that's going to go
millions of nations have gone before us
billions of people trillions of people
have died
yes and we're going to die also and
we're going to stand in front of allah
have your five minutes of oppression
have you a couple of minutes of you know
theft you know stealing people's land or
pressing them kicking them out from
their own houses no problem
because the eternity in the hereafter
you're going to see inshallah this is
just the plan of allah do your
oppression because all it's going to do
is going to backfire on you
inshallah the day will come palestine
inshallah
will be free and they will be inshallah
do not worry inshallah a day will come
inshaallah subhanallah brothers and
sisters inshallah and salahuddin
subhanallah when he came and defeated
the crusaders and subhanallah he allowed
the jews
the jews to live there subhanallah and
now today you have all jews some of them
are amazing people
and you have these zionist jews doing
subhanallah look what they're doing to
the muslims allah subhanahu wa will tell
us just from sisters
and as long as we stick to the quran
allah elevates promises to do not think
liberation has come going to come via
some armies we saw what happened when
egypt and the other uh forces the arab
world came
to attack uh israel um was it for the
sake of allah
i highly doubt i highly doubt and that's
why we got humiliated and we will carry
again humiliated
as long as we do not uphold allah's
quran and the son of the prophet peace
be upon him until next time assalamu
alaikum
share this video far and wide because
youtube might limit it let's
make it unlimited you're finished